[الموسيقى]
تفعل أكثر قليلاً بهذه الطريقة ثم
تعوض الاستعداد
لافتتاح أحد أكبر الأحداث في العالم
يبدو شيئًا كهذا
بمثابة بروفة دقيقة لمئات من
الراقصين والمنتجين
ومصممي الرقصات الذين يتابعونني ،
سيكون عرضًا رائعًا  لأنه سيجمع
ليس فقط العروض الحية في جميع أنحاء
Edward plaza ، ولكنه سيشمل أيضًا عرضًا
رائعًا وموسيقى مذهلة
في غضون أسبوعين فقط ، ستكون أعين العالم
هنا عندما تفتح أبواب
معرض دبي إكسبو 2020 في الأول من أكتوبر
، وتتمثل مهمة الحدث العالمي في  تعزيز
التعاون الاقتصادي والثقافي بين
كبار صانعي السياسات
وقادة الأعمال ، موضوعنا الشامل
في إكسبو 2020 هو ربط العقول
لخلق المستقبل
[الموسيقى]
تقليديًا ، كان المعرض مكانًا
لعرض أحدث التقنيات
والابتكارات.
الأحداث الكبيرة وجود مادي هجين جديد
وتجربة افتراضية
قد يرغب بعض الأشخاص في القدوم إليها
ولكن قد لا يتمكنون فعليًا من
زيارة موقع المعرض
فعليًا وزيارة الأجنحة فعليًا حتى
لحضور بعض الأحداث التي
كنا من أوائل الدول
في العالم التي أطلقت جولة افتراضية في
جناحنا تمامًا كما لو كانت
في الطابق العلوي  يقول مدير جناح المملكة المتحدة
مهدي طاهر إن
التجارب الافتراضية هي في صميم
عرض البلاد ،
فنحن نبني منصة لنكون قادرين على
نقل جميع أحداثنا عبر الإنترنت.
كل ما تحتاجه هو الوصول إلى متصفح الويب
الذي حرصنا عليه حقًا للتأكد من أن
أولئك الذين لا يستطيعون الوصول فعليًا إلى هنا ما
زالوا منشغلين ومندمجين في
المحتوى الذي يخرج من هنا
وكان هذا هو محور تركيز منظمي المعرض الذين
يسمحون بالافتراضية  للمسافرين
لاستكشاف كل ركن من أركان موقعهم الذي تبلغ مساحته 1080 فدانًا
باستخدام أدوات لجذب حتى أصغر
جمهور ،
لدينا أيضًا عرض إكسبو 2020 في
عالم ماين كرافت  d التي ستتيح
للجمهور الأصغر سنًا تجربة
رحلة تعليمية خاصة عبر
منصة ماين كرافت
للاستفادة من إمكانات
الواقع الافتراضي والأدوات الرقمية ،
سيكون حفل الافتتاح أول حدث من بين العديد من
الأحداث الافتراضية التي ستصاحب
التجربة المادية للأشهر الستة المقبلة
آنا  ستيوارت سي إن